and in one of these like just high
intense moments i was like i'll have
your babies
hi i'm scarlett johansson and i'm
florence pugh and we will be answering
fans questions for lag bible where were
you when you found out black widow was
going to die
and how did you react i was i was home
on the phone
uh with kevin feige and
i don't know how i reacted i think i was
like okay
i mean i think all of us sort of were
thinking
we kind of would all joke with one
another about how
who was gonna get off uh in the end uh
game but
i was a little you know i was i was i
was
heartbroken about it uh but also you
know
i think i took it like a champ i cried
in the shower later
but nobody saw that part what was your
first star struck moment and with who
um i saw patrick stewart once
on an airplane i was probably like 11.
poor patrick stewart he had just put his
eye mask on
and i went over to tapped him on the
shoulder he very like sweetly lifted it
up it was me
i couldn't believe it was patrick
stewart and then i asked for his
autograph
and he so sweetly signed to me and when
i said something like
sweet dreams scarlett love patrick
stewart
so thanks thanks pat for being such a
gem
me i say my proper like oh my god i felt
like
one of the beatles fans and could have
potentially fainted
was me and my mate cued at the front
in at latitude festival we queued for
hours to see paolo nutini
and i i i was just i could not believe
that potentially his spit could land on
me that's kind of how close i was
and in one of these like just high
intense moments i was like i have your
babies
and i was probably about 15
and i remember he was just about to do
like his song and he looked down in my
direction and did like his little
paolo nutini smirk and i was like
i could die a happy woman
[Laughter]
if you could have the powers abilities
of any avenger
who would you choose and why
i i think i would probably go
with scarlet witch uh
i really just want to know how to do
those weird hand gestures
they're like i don't know she does like
it looks like she's basically it's like
a 90s rave
situation oh yeah
that was just me being a crab
you know what i think i'd be thor
why just because of the hair
yeah definitely the hair because the
hair looks better than my hair just the
the to be able to just throw that
big heavy hammer and only you can grab
it
interesting choice you you would just
like
throw like the golden retriever of
avengers
if you were to teach scarlet some
british slang what would it be
um gotta spend a penny is going for a
wii
huh i gotta go spend a penny because in
the day in the olden days uh the toilets
the public toilets would cost a penny
and so you'd say i've got to go spend a
penny what are all those weird
foods that you guys uh that have like
weird names spotted dick is a pudding
which is like a log
uh like spongy thing with is it with
chocolate and raisins in it
i think i'm weird just change the name
no one needs it to be called that
i don't like that i don't like the name
or it sounds like something i wouldn't
like
no it's like a log that sounds worse
okay is this what um woody harrelson
eats in that zombie film i've always
wanted
to try one of these if this is bad i'm
gonna be so disappointed
oh it's a bit damp though
oh that looks minging
no what is that that's disgusting